alessandra we are here at PAX West 2019
and you and I just got to play Avengers
The Avengers video game from Crystal
Dynamics you saw it at e3 but now you
got to play it what were your
impressions your your basic impressions
well first off um I feel like I have a
better picture of like you know what
this game is just all about as you
recall during our chat during e3 uh you
know I had a I had some difficulties
trying to sort of understand how this
was sort of like a destiny style
experience and they focused this time
this presentation was about what this
game is they admitted like hey a lot of
you're very clear you don't quite
understand what this game was so now we
are going to go through the four pillars
of this game or whatever yeah the
tenants of this game sure we actually
basically got to go hands-on with that
section they showed off during e3 the
entire San Francisco section so yes okay
it was very much like going one room
beat up some guys cutscene change
characters beat up some guys yes it was
a tutorial yeah it was a tutorial so
they said the game will open up more as
you play but I wasn't super impressed
with that opening yeah I feel like um
maybe the biggest problem I still have
with the game is just like how it sort
of bounces a sort of like Batman Arkham
so rolling gameplay with sort of like
the leat aspect of the game the
levelling one thing they did add a
comparison to the in comparison to the
other III sort of presentation was that
you could actually see the enemy levels
and help ores to I guess make things a
little bit more clear that yeah of an
action RPG game yeah so basically the
general idea of the game is that you get
to customize your superheroes by giving
them different different WEP or what
pieces armor pieces which don't affect
their cosmetics that's only the the
outfit which you can buy or unlock in
game and basically you're gonna be
playing through levels in order to get
more gear new characters and yeah mid
max your character if you're into that
and we actually got to see like the
actual like menu screen and all the loot
look very much like destiny yeah I mean
like you actually had like the character
like player like sort of banner will
like you know there's sort of power
ranking your character your player name
and also the loot has is very much like
the familiar color-coded color-coded
purple is good yes purple is good you
want purple than anything above so I
mean essentially it is an action RPG
that's co-op with Avengers with Avengers
and you you can pick your mission so
there is a what do they call hero
missions and those are solo missions
specific for your hero and there are war
zones where items which are co-op
multiplayer on yeah
the hero missions are basically sort of
I guess you can say standard like
campaign missions very much focused on a
particular character so that's how you
move the story for it basically by doing
all these heroic missions yeah then you
do the war zones which are the more
online focus like you know but they also
made it very clear you can do that
soldier solo as well so it'll scale and
they said they want to emphasize that
this is a game for everyone yes because
you know lots of kids are gonna be
playing of course an Avengers video game
so you don't have to min/max if you want
to do some of the tougher stuff but
they'll help out a lot yeah throughout
their presentation
the following presentation after we got
to go hands-on they were very clear and
trying to sort of you know make certain
aspects of the game like you know a lot
more presentable like yeah I think the
big takeaway they had from ether ooze
that you know just what kind of game is
this like you know and yeah I feel like
I have a better understanding of what
that is but I still I'm still trying to
sort of maybe try to reconcile sort of
different like sort of gameplay pillars
and like how they come together but my
biggest concern I think is that a lot of
these games tend to have a rocky launch
so I hope they can beat that especially
because it is Marvel and all these
superheroes that people know I want it
to be good I mean yeah it's really cool
it could be really cool yeah but again
it's just I mean how is this gonna work
I mean like
that's just something that's sort of
lingering with me even after going
hands-on with it I remember talking to
you about it and just yeah I feel better
about it now than I did at e3 but I
still you know sort of have some
hesitation and then the other
interesting thing with the story is what
they should off Captain America it goes
down with the ship and they're like what
happened to Captain America yeah and
they're like next slide here's all of
his different costumes you can get and
it's like alright so Captain America
there's no still enough yeah he's
Captain America will be in the game
along with a bunch of other heroes yes
they said they'll be adding new heroes
new areas for free yep event uh we
actually got to see Kamala
Miss Marvel in one of the cutscenes and
the demo was also she was there briefly
but you know that it was Kamala so I'm
pretty sure she might you know show up
you know later on in the game as well
alright well let us know what you think
of Marvel's Avengers and for more pax
coverage stay tuned GameSpot
you